hi guys you know how much I love to get
terrified on camera for you and now the
outlast 2 is out that game is no
exception I have been live streaming it
for you and I have cut down the first
few hours into video format for you to
enjoy before we get into the let play
though I might say a quick thank you to
Blue Microphones for giving me a Yeti
microphone it's really helped set up the
quality of the content I can deduce and
I'm just really really grateful for them
so thank you very much good it contains
graphic sexual content since when I
didn't really play the first one I paid
half of it okay
Lynn's Langerman is an investigative
journalist seeking the answers behind a
something that is behind my head
pregnant woman oh behind a pregnant
woman married under impossible
circumstances in rural Arizona you are
Blake Langerman her husband assistance
and government record everything neither
of your fighters to navigate the horrors
waiting to you in the desert your only
choices are to run hide or die
definitely don't want the last one
they're still thing outlast would be an
even cooler game if at the end of the
game you actually got to saw the footage
that you were taking when you pledged
support
[Music]
like our Charlie sleeping Hoek you
should have slept last night I had to
get that hospital footage organized
you're calling up some other one oh what
a sleep Jessica I think you know it
Jessica
oh no I mean I was dreaming about
Jessica dream from when we were kids
oh yeah I haven't thought about her
aegis we recorded intro while we're up
here production Olli sure coward my
diaphragm just single oh you're gonna be
crap I'll have to all [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're good exciting get as much of the
left behind as you can okay I don't
we're good this is my mother Helen on a
red leather yellow how do i do you have
a cola okay I'm Lin Lang Herrmann here
for you tomorrow dotnet where's Caroline
past the Havasupai Indian Reservation in
central Arizona in search of the origins
of murder Mikael Intelli I don't think
you should say murdered we don't know
that
oh she strangled herself to death so
what the police report says we might
play this before the doctor interviews
and for the first 30 we need to get the
more murderer in there
we should probably much puffiness two of
you know just here let me try immersion
my concern I drove for the whole piece
tell me what are good okay Morgan two
weeks ago a young woman found wandering
barefoot pregnant and alone on a barren
stretch of highway 100 mile
well
[Music]
did you fall guessing she fell guess
what the Popo wash your on another
feature here it's super super dark this
to Jessica
so this is a gala he was dreaming about
so I'm guessing is he dreaming again you
get to a Catholic school I went to a
Texas
career um
[Music]
obviously Oh
okay yeah he was dreaming
oh no way would that still work not
possible [ __ ] this Liz wait it's just
like my actual plans I actually take hey
hey yes wife so happy now you can
actually see what you can code look at
my amazing recording skills my head Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
next potato didn't happen what the hell
will they thank you
and we for fireplace awesome jump time
here no oh how puffy honest to get that
having our guide ah this way I see
[Music]
[Music]
okay this works much for Evan just
jumped in town okay
I was a boy
[Music]
we I really like that they've added this
like the camera actually has looked Nagi
now it's good problem that my cool
[Music]
finally nothing matters but with nobody
not even man to ever find it okay
yeah I can't see anything when of it oh
my god me [ __ ] that's the pilot not
having the crash
doesn't seem to have a battery that I
need to worry about which is good
please that would be nice we don't have
to worry about battery and this is
behind my head I hope not oh my god
what am i lonely about oh this was the
start of the demo I remember this
[Music]
graphic whoa
I'm lost and her
stay there please Jesus hey hey man I
remember all that oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you're
my dear sweet Eddie I can't bear what
we've done what we've done how can you
forgive me for leaving you behind and
God forgive me this last trespass I know
that we had to be offered up but I'm all
tore up inside and can't live no more
hopefully the end will come soon and we
can we'll be together again and that's
got fans and forever for this sin until
then I hope you find what woman's
comfort you need in the arms of path or
not
did he give his kids away sounds like it
well darn it we do need batteries okay
look in your left pocket to interrupt
with your batteries okay oh gosh okay
now yeah
I think the battery is behind my head
that's gonna let me yeah there it is
okay now I can see okay
I need to reload our battery because I'm
using this a lot and then I put it down
I can't see anything with ours oh five
can I know
what what what
I remember I gotta hide in the Bible
- hi
[Music]
where to go
okay oh oh no no no no no [ __ ]
tomorrow back in the battle why is all
screaming oh god I don't remember these
did this happen in the demo I can't
remember okay
I'm strong foot from it can I'm private
rice as well
that was cool I could be like a little
puppet from school okay right let's go
no I don't hide one of my batteries
though I can't even see without is that
Kizer holding a little thingy okay
I can hide there I don't know what that
is batteries see you so talk without
using this okay what spell oh I don't
even notice this before I wouldn't have
noticed this if you didn't kind of make
look at it and lots of babies right wait
so dark I can't see any of the
jump-scare demon all right this is just
like the demo
get up
[Music]
please went he had the whole away
I want to read it midwives with lights
payment the baby's coming
ready tonight the baby's coming Knights
midwife mother to the enemy stains with
in God's creation safe within oh it's a
son Julio's knees no no longer mother
wait so came that came the dawn the
enemy born to die in temple gate the
baby is growing her baby swells the
baby's growing sent from Hell excited
waits in sharpening his blade I don't
make them excited by the hollister
gather at the gate we Milla play so
mother ma like trying to conceive baby
baby demons it seems like they are yes
draw crispy body
Hey
that's creepy
they have made this way creepier than
the demo that it just added a bunch
hey where's the Wow welcome very well
around here there is no well now they've
taken the well away is there a factory
you baby
okay there was a well that before was or
maybe the well is through here I can't
remember
that's tough where is it where was that
what
[Music]
I don't like you told me like that and
my freakin eeeh it's pretty like right
in my ear - I don't like it I used to
talk like that to my friends when I was
a kid it was like
hey back stop it if it actually
disappears oh oh [ __ ] what do I do
what do I do go-go's Oh rabbit go go go
Robert go go go run my mom by the way
get it here good evening what the [ __ ]
are you doing you idiot get in the
window you just opened it get in finally
nothing matters but win yeah I'm just
looking at my family okay
[Music]
fingers crossed and saying the battery
head I'm never going to change it from
maturity though because I want to get
the most out of my battery okay
run run run run run run run men men men
men men men men men
Oh ride up and I don't know why I'm
going come on look under here curl under
okay get ahead army I don't know where
where am I
what are those things anyway where am i
pushing you then I like you
no why would I hate him Rize like that
little voice I think I do this and then
I can show little man and I can tell her
laughs okay yes keep going to go on Yard
Man
this little creepy kid in there not know
I'm gonna freak
Oh Oh Daniel Hamm goodness I thought you
were a kid with the reaper mix with the
reaper
I think I'm doing very well sorry these
more batteries by this little barrel can
we tied in good no batteries good okay
saving that's good sign looks like this
is completely changed from heightened
high waist
yeah it completely changed from the demo
which is good because I thought I have
to do that whole thing again okay what
am I going to
I just want the wheel on oh I can hear
through walls that's pretty cool wait
hot white wolf enjoy passion
so my face is looking frame confuse ok
so there's someone swinging in the next
room thanks for letting me waste my
battery to find out those are swinging
go there Oh hazel is just like okay so
dear babies are bad news Papapa Papapa
Papapa
I like that the music kind of goes down
so it's me in the house I want to go in
there can I go in now I thought you left
the house which was the open the door
I'm gonna go in don't know what I'm
doing I can't see
Oh am I in no what am i doing right
anybody's in you hold the batteries here
okay I'm sorry doesn't barrel right next
to me
oh I'm gonna have to find batteries a
little Gary so get back all you have to
be using night vision all the time yes I
do have you seen our back it is
I can't freaking see anything I can see
something now
haha I don't know where I'm going
with the fake wood laughter oh my god
daddy
first time itself members essence about
loving brother go marina Leah go go go
go go
I have and that all there is to it we
stand in opposition to the Antichrist
if we open ways away
we cannot only fly to be like Jesus
we hate to be she's not God God has sent
us just woman billions over the sky no
Jessica Oh
it's my teammate okay
the yl baby any batteries
I cannot read that
I want to make sure they don't hurt my
pilot buddy
to me children
they're mine
giving you alive give me your children
Oh baby what that is my gaming sense
take me down give me the sweet
Fantasia's you hate all my anger
oh yeah thank y'all honey
as you get back each year I'm asking
that you tell him aurorus and story that
I hope it's only my peers and nothing
factual the chief among his deacons vow
came to me before sunrise this morning
with an offer that was not fully
described without acted like somebody
offering something secret and sexual in
nature but by my knowledge of vowel and
his character it frightened me terribly
and I would not accept that in such
invitation I would not rather explain
and told me that there are places in our
hearts suffer no cannot reach although
truth be told well seems more interested
in other areas of my body I have vowed
to return to his evening oats I had a
chance to think it over but if only to
that enough might may send some men of
form vow of love of art something cuts
off before any what the hell okay so
basically some people here across it's
sexually corrupt they're all Jim new
religious and I'm guessing they
shouldn't be sexual
[Music]
find lit nothing that public pretty cool
that you actually get to see your
inventory this way gonna pretty
realistic way
[Music]
oh the blood I should have seen the
blood oh I was talking I miss the Prez
jump-scare so you didn't scare me but
nice try though haven't had to use that
again
now look in the fridge No okay so
through the jam tall high fall under the
bed
something is like an animal babies and
I'm using this and I run out of battery
so I don't want to read them but I
always like reading things nice I don't
know any of our batteries because this
game is ridiculously yard okay
how they doing to her like like stopping
Carol this yet ah okay I was supposed to
do that house like on my beam suspension
hey yeah yeah hey God please okay no
what the [ __ ] no need to run and the
outside okay oh I just oh then where are
we going
away from here anywhere but here
oh god Monica they invited in heaven
he's wrong
[ __ ] they have all she wanted my heart
doesn't look so dumb I just described
Lynn what's happening here if you're
dead cells ago we were all dead at that
yeah we're gonna get out okay guess what
did they do to you panic you can't ask
about it
we've been awaiting all this time what
we have I perform in Sabadell Thank You
hane they were patron of you know who's
gonna get out of here and I think made
me really not now special hey wait
moms at me another battle okay
Oh erm on their progress the gang
bracelet I think there's a problem Ellie
I'm crunching these i'm gonna gay-bash
where to [ __ ] right the first person
touches me loses their eyes son wants to
sow into shall be javi son my pleasure
red no you know
yeah
[ __ ] you
oh right no way no no babe [ __ ] and why
is on me
[Music]
[Music]
we have Norman
I think I'll see you again
nope I'm here if I am so I'm guessing
business from this and the other groups
were obviously religious again Oh
sheriff on the deer baby
oh yeah okay well I'm not high you could
have done it oh I don't forget to check
me out every Wednesday night at 9:00
p.m. which is when I'm usually
live-streaming but do follow me on
Twitter for updates on whether I'm going
to do some more streams during the week
or whether that might change to sometime
versus this you know life gets and
higher things but live-streaming is so
much fun
I absolutely love doing for you guys
chatting to you in real-time singing you
a little song at the end of games it's
such a nice environment and just lovely
to chat the community and see you guys
getting to know each other as well so if
you are free do come along
anyway thank you for watching and have a
lovely evening
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]